humans have been making silk for
centuries it's a coveted textile for
gowns sheets and robes but why is it so
expensive silk is the product of the
domesticated silkworm Bombyx mori the
caterpillars eat constantly they're fed
mulberry leaves five times a day after
45 days of munching and growing the
worms are ready to mature they have a
special spin aret that secretes one long
continuous filament that's the silk the
silkworms spin this filament into a
cocoon then the caterpillar begins its
transformation except this is when silk
producers but in the cocoons are steamed
this cleans them and kills the pupae
inside if the pupils were kept alive
they would degrade and break the silk
then the cocoons are unraveled to reveal
around half a mile of usable filament
filaments are joined to create a thread
thick enough to weave into fabric one
yard of silk fabric costs approximately
$100 what makes it worth the cost we
spoke to a few experts on the subject to
find out Sean Jacobs is the creative
director and president of wedding dress
design house and barge she says quote
the cost of producing silk garments has
gone up dramatically
unquote consumers accustomed to
synthetic materials like polyester
expect perfection
she also says quote silk is expensive
because it's a natural fiber and
therefore has imperfections this has led
to an increase of waste in production
which raises the overall cost knowing
this quality control expenses also go up
to ensure that the final product meets
our standards unquote professor daniel
Nicodemo credits silks price tag to its
thermal conductivity and sturdiness it's
also easily dyed and doesn't cause skin
irritation so what do you think is silk
worth the cost
you